your company generates lots of data but
the business outcomes you gain from that
data can be largely affected by data
quality
to use an analogy imagine you're a chef
and you have the highest accolades in
the industry a highly experienced team
but when the ingredients come in those
are poor quality ingredients picture
rotten tomatoes rotten onions so when
you go and make those entrees the end
result is poor quality and your
restaurant's reputation suffers
this is the same impact that poor data
quality can have on your business
causing your company's reputation to
suffer as a result
there are a lot of different factors
that can impact data quality such as the
number of sources or the size of your
company but today i want to talk about
four main qualities within data itself
accuracy unit completeness consistency
and uniqueness
and i'm going to talk about them through
the lens of a lead generation company
starting with accuracy
accuracy is about the current state of
your data versus reality
so for my lead generation company
imagine i'm driving traffic to a website
and all of a sudden i get a sudden spike
in usage from bots that hit the click
generation
if i don't account for this spike when i
go and pull that data at the end of the
day it's not going to reflect reality so
it's not going to be accurate
next i want to talk about completeness
which is about how you have filled out
all the required fields
in your data set
so let's say i'm launching a survey
campaign
and i'm collecting
names and email addresses
but i don't require this field so when i
go and pull that data i notice that some
of my participants didn't put their name
some of my participants didn't put their
email so when i go and pull that picture
of the client of the customer i have an
incomplete data set and a complete
picture
next we talk about consistency which is
about how uniform
your data set is throughout different
data sources
so back to my lead generation example
let's say i'm driving traffic for a drop
shipping campaign
and i have my procurement team
collecting zip codes and my marketing
team collecting zip codes but my
procurement team is looking at them
in a five digit format while my
marketing team is collecting them in a
nine digit format
when i go tap into both of these
databases and pull the customer profile
it might be incomplete because those zip
codes don't match up throughout my
systems
and lastly there's uniqueness which is
largely tied to the number of duplicates
i have in a data set
so in my lead generation context you can
imagine having 50 000 leads at the end
of the year but when i actually go into
those leads i realize that 20
are duplicates from customers who filled
out the information previously so now
when i go and pull that report i
actually have 20 percent less data and a
lot
less
positive looking picture for my company
so
looking at these aspects it's easy to
think wow there's a lot of manual
inspection here how can i go through all
of my data and understand these
resources these
qualities right well you can actually
leverage machine learning and ai to
automatically sense these key features
as data enters your system saving you
time and manual inspection
if you're curious about these ai
features check out the links below and
if you're curious about technology
subscribe to the channel thank you